welcome to this video playing entire
duck from Prague it is Australia or New
Zealand its Australia losing it is a bit
different but not entirely okay so let's
see a trompe i'm going to name in them
international ah Sir Andrew Brown okay
yeah the Society's is in fact a line
it's a sort of black modem again but
would be four but I just ignore that
play play in French style don't want to
grab horns and give them huge
compensation okay doesn't play five this
is Sir but weird usually you go eat five
with white and then a quick Bishop e3 so
that you can play C 3 + f4 to bolster
the center this to be honest looks a
quite strange the cheek I'm not I'm not
really winning material but take take
you for okay I cannot grab default it's
clear but yeah okay let's let's continue
here spending too much time trying to
refute try to look for a refutation
maybe there is one because it really
looks strange but
ok
so this tries to exploit this strange
piece set up with Bishop f4 92 idea is
to play de Knight g4 and then it's
tricky I'll get a 5 back and i also have
ideas like we'd be six Bishop c5 and
another move the night only to was just
not helping it all with the center Wow
very strange if I go Knight g4 you can
play Bishop b5 checking but i also have
Queen a5 and trying to get this back
here giving away the the dark squared
Bishop is very stranger this position
check it just strategically terrible
because I mean my queen 35 already
hunter there are other pieces that can
use the square night bishop so so soon
very nice for black
okay so many possible continuations
Bishop Bishop 36 for example this one of
them just are just threatening made
okay me a spurious look at five and
moves like that this is some this is in
the position
yeah yeah those pieces are not so so
well coordinated
problem is some 222 m to not get get
tactically kilobots in the next moves
then then it's it's it's excellent ok
but he's attacking here and here
yeah they are interesting why did I go
wrong very interesting I mean this was
completely anti positional play by white
after Queenie fiber should be in
excellent shape I did something wrong
I'm not sure what
very strange can we pour down I mean I
still have some some compensation for
that but it's of course not what I
should have after the beginning of the
game compensation lies in the fact that
i have this potentially better bishop
and his knights are somewhat tied
together but still it's upon some and
struck him
hmm
hmm i go here knight c6 is not good to
know yep and i came
trying to increase the pressure yet I
rookie 19 he's got ok one look F to you
one yeah the only move but it's
sufficient
okay i still can go here
not seasick I can take c3m should be
okay I wonder if you can play 96 check
didn't do that
came not sure that i have calculated
this correctly check but it should be it
should be ok I'll go here and it's got
knight c6 and d7 threatened son ok let's
block the pawn ok now can take it check
I get this exam check how to do that
let's secure the on the h1 for the
moment maybe I can get can set up a
meeting trap rock be too threatening g4
and mate ok let's gain some space check
now and now I get the phone is getting
that one I've got about them ok i just
noticed that i went on time she didn't
really really look at the clock check
time morning check white forfeits on
time hmm what a strange game I mean so
why am I not winning right out of the
opening I mean probably because of my
own stupidity on the meter level but
what are the exact moves I mean this is
something that blacks should should
really punish maybe it that may be
really really Bishop b5 some
this is the the key point since kissable
that really helps him I mean if he would
not have there should be five here then
let's say I have I have the porn on a
six out then the black Islam was winning
strategically to bishops and this
fantastic square that is largely
uncontested he cannot really check the
Queen them but the time this is of
course very important it just gained
some time for white I need to spend time
to to cover the night and suddenly
there's this rook f12 f5 IDM yeah maybe
maybe I can really play that but I
wasn't sure this looked looked tricky
maybe it's not a problem this is what
the comb suggests suggests g6 a bit of a
lazy moves here Knight f6 is clearly
better for black interesting
probably get the porner can only be
protected by the Queen another ticket it
probably needs to move to to some square
where something happened that one who
was also interesting and that okay that
gets to the end game where I think I
have some slight compensation but
probably yet sets not sufficient really
yeah this is probably not great but hard
to tell even a three I thought I could I
could go for that banking on this porn
but maybe what is just winning its poor
soul yeah already we were very much
download time but the key point and the
most interesting thing is during the
game I really thought that check like
it's close to winning here and it would
be the case but this Bishop b5 as usual
shank replay strong porn than general
considerations and this should be still
okay for white with cream b3 actually
what you didn't do interesting game
thanks for watching